make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we're continuing our quest to
cover all of the omega-level mutant for
this series and in this video we are
talking about Exodus now Exodus was
created by Scott Liddell and Joe Quesada
and made his first appear as an x-factor
number 92 in 1993 so he's a relatively
new character at least compared to a lot
of the characters that we cover which
have been around since the 1960s and
even the 1970s or 80s but as far as his
origin goes Exodus actually has a pretty
interesting story
so Exodus dates back to the 12th century
when he was a French Crusader named
Bennett du petit now along with a man
named Leo bargue errington who is
basically the Black Knight at the time
sought out something called the tower of
power in Jordan now eventually the Black
Knight basically gave up on the quest
and Exodus continued the journey himself
travelling through severe sandstorms and
eventually giving in to the elements and
collapsing now he ends up hearing a
voice that tells him that in order to
gain strength that he needs to be
willing to risk everything and this is
when his mutant powers were first
demonstrated when Bennett simply
disappeared now later it was revealed
that Bennett had actually been found by
the villain apocalypse and transformed
into Exodus
now apocalypse ends up commanding Exodus
to kill the Black Knight and Circe who's
been searching for ultimately of course
Exodus ended up refusing but I should
point out this is not the same black
knight that Exodus had fought alongside
and in fact this was actually the 20th
century black knight a guy by the name
of Dane Wittman who had traveled back in
time regardless after he refused the
order from apocalypse apocalypse
vanishes Exodus - a tomb in the Alps
where he remained for six months in a
comatose state before being found by the
Black Knight however
apocalypse had placed a spell on the
tomb that did not allow Exodus to leave
so we essentially remained there until
the 20th century when he was eventually
discovered by Magneto now magneto was
able to free Exodus from his
imprisonment and took him to his space
station on asteroid M where Exodus
became one of Magneto's acolytes and
basically his second-in-command
due to his zealous devotion to the cause
of mutant supremacy now in the following
years
Exodus wouldn't make repeated
appearances as an antagonist to the
x-men and most recently appeared in
Jonathan Hickman's house of X miniseries
coming to Agricola along with several
other villains when Professor X declares
that bacala is a place where all mutants
are welcome now once on curco
exodus has given a seat at the quiet
council and is thus one of 14 people
responsible for creating the laws of
cacoa
itself and so the question becomes what
are exodus powers well this guy is an
absolute demon most notably he's a
powerful telekinetic and telepath he can
produce energy blast teleport and fly as
well as possessing superhuman strength
and durability but what makes Exodus
omega-level is definitely his prowess
and telekinesis and telepathy he's able
to use his telekinesis offensively to
crush boulders and buildings and damage
and even vaporize his opponent he can
also create telekinetic shield to
protect him from damage including a
punch from rockslide and a blast from
cables gun which has been shown to be
powerful enough to damage the Red Hawk
Exodus is able to create psionic
barriers and even produce one that was
large enough to cut off communication to
the entire island of Genosha he's able
to move objects on an atomic level as he
did when he rebuilt professor X's brain
after Xavier had been shot in the head
he's also been able to take apart
sentinels and shield helicarrier's
telekinetically turning the ladder into
a cerebro scanner now in addition to his
telekinesis Exodus is one of the
strongest telepaths in the Marvel
Universe he's displayed an ability to
telepathically overpower Jean Grey
Scarlet Witch and crystal of the
Inhumans simultaneously all at the same
time he was able to block a psychic
probe from Jean Grey while his attention
was focused on a battle with a powerful
mutant named Holocaust in terms of just
how he ranks as a telepath psylocke has
stated that he's a stronger telepath
than she is but he was ultimately
defeated by Charles Xavier in a psychic
battle despite initially holding his own
now he's also shown impressive
teleportation abilities being able to
teleport multiple individuals from earth
to a space station temporarily
Exodus was able to siphon the psionic
energy from others near him and use it
to restore him from a weakened state
although there really hasn't been any
recent evidence to show that he's still
able to do this and so yeah that's
basically what we know about Bennet
right this guy's an absolute demon when
it comes to telepathy and telekinesis
this is a sort of video maybe we can do
a character explanation on Exodus and
kind of feel like we should because
Exodus is an absolute monster when it
comes to facing off against the x-men
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come and to explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph Ben
john h aj Matt and Jeff are John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin Asia OEM Steven Z
Austin be Adam K and Genesis 9 16
remember guys you could see me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long as
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there send me an email
Rob at Robert Jefferson calm and if
you're one of these people who get
shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]
you
[Music]